merci à tous alexandre a m'a demandé de
venir parler d'art oratoire sous ce
prisme les règles de l'art et avec
l'idée que s'il existe des règles de
l'art en tout cas dans l'art oratoire et
bien on se retrouve à parler d'une façon
figé avec un ensemble de scénarios qu'on
aurait été pré définis à l'avancé et
fatalement on peut plus répondre ou en
tout cas on peut plus exprimer ou
inventés et être capable de répondre à
des situations où un environnement qui
sans cesse nous demande d'être plus
créatifs et d'être capable d'être
disruptif alors j'ai envie de vous poser
une question quand on parle de règles de
l'art et d'art oratoire qui regarde en
ce moment roland garros ok est-ce qu'il
ya certaines personnes parmi vous qui
ont pratiqué des arts d'interprètes
alors lézarde interprète c'est le
théâtre c'est le chant la danse faire de
la musique par exemple
voilà ça peut même être le cours de
flûte en 6e ou la représentation de fin
d'année en cm2 un jeu en général on en
garde des souvenirs
donc il ya à pratiquer ça ok donc est ce
que vous imaginez que vous auriez pu
monter sur scène et jouer danser et
chanter sans que vous ayez répéter sans
que vous ayez pu vous appuyez sur une
technique faire vos gammes par exemple
pour un chanteur ou pour un musicien est
ce que vous imaginez que les champions
que vous voyez sur les courts de tennis
sont là sans avoir jamais tapé de balle
contre un mur ou sans avoir travaillé
leur appui on est d'accord non alors
vous me direz c'est quoi le rapport avec
l'art oratoire et bien le rapport c'est
que l'art oratoire
c'est un art d'interprète alors on va
pas interpréter la pensée d'un tiers on
va pas interpréter la pensée de molière
quand il écrit don juan ou l'imaginaire
la création d'un compositeur vous allez
interpréter votre propre pensée c'est à
dire vous êtes des auteurs quand vous
avez un message à faire passer quand
vous avez une connaissance que vous les
transmettre
eh bien vous êtes les auteurs de cette
connaissance et puis à un moment cette
connaissance la face un public même une
seule personne
il va falloir la verbaliser trouver les
mots les plus justes pour l'exprimer en
regard de la singularité du public que
vous avez en face de vous
l'art oratoire et donc anar
d'interprètes on structure sa pensée
dans l'action il n'y a pas de texte qui
a été pré écrit à l'avancé
contrairement aux acteurs par exemple
qui jouent des textes pré écrit al
avance et contrairement aussi à ce qu'on
peut s'imaginer de ce qu'est l'art
oratoire parce que si cette question se
pose concernant l'art oratoire à savoir
est ce que les règles en ferme c'est
parce que souvent on a la sensation vont
confond ça avec la rhétorique et la
rhétorique comprendrait que par le petit
bout de l'âme de la lorgnette la
rhétorique je sais pas si ça vous
dis quelque chose je sais pas si vous
avez participé à des aides à des clubs
de rhétorique alors y en a pas beaucoup
dans la culture anglo saxonne ça fait
fureur un petit peu moins ici en france
vous ça vous dit quelque chose et
participer à ce type de club du racing
club
voilà très bien la rhétorique quand on
prend par le petit bout de la lorgnette
on associe sa à ce qu'on appelle les
locutions c'est à dire des formes
stylistique utiliser une métaphore
utilisée une question reto rhétorique
utilisée l'allégorie la synecdoque etc
on a ceux ci ça aussi à ce que cicéron
et aristote appelé la disposition donc
comment mettre ces éléments ensemble
en gros on a un peu cette souvent en
tout cas cette idée que ça correspond à
un nombre de scénarios prédéfinis et il
s'agirait quand vous parlez de les
imposer à votre public d'essayer de
sentir maintien qu'est ce que je vais
lui balancer que j'ai déjà préparé et et
sans inventer pour le coup donc
effectivement si on pense que l'art
oratoire c'est ça alors oui les règles
sont tout à fait bloquante et vous
empêche d'inventer et vous empêche de
créer et d'être de pouvoir répondre de
passe de façon pertinente dans votre
discours face à un environnement qui est
constamment changeant sauf que l'art
oratoire c'est pas ça c'est à la fois
comme vous disais une technique
d'interprète
mais c'est allé plus loin que ce qu'on a
prévu de dire grâce à son public c'est
se mettre dans une situation où c'est le
public on dit qui vient faire son marché
dans ma tête c'est à dire c'est vous qui
me guider par vos réactions par votre
existence par votre singularité et vous
êtes unique ce soir dans l'état où vous
êtes
et quand bien même je parlerai devant
vous demain bah vous serez encore
différent et c'est votre singularité
votre particularité qui va faire que
compte tenu d'une connaissance que j'ai
sur un sujet eh ben je la formule est
d'une certaine façon
grâce à vous donc le rôle de
l'environnement de la personne à qui on
s'adresse est fou
un mental et c'est ça qui fait qu'on est
capable de créer c'est ça qui fait qu'on
ne connaît pas son texte à l'avancé
parce que dans la nature même de l'art
oratoire inventé aller plus loin eh bien
ça fait partie justement de la nature de
l'art oratoire
alors maintenant c'est vrai que c'est
aussi théorique ce que je vous raconte
retenez simplement c'est un art
d'interprète et cet art-là consiste à
créer son texte
grâce au public et c'est ça qui fait que
vous serez pertinents parce que le
public
dans ces cas là il devient le co auteur
du texte définitif jeu
en gros ce que je vais vous raconter là
maintenant je savais pas ce que c'était
avant de vouloir voir 10 et jamais plus
je leur dirai de cette façon ça nous
appartient à vous et à moi et à chaque
fois il faut se remettre dans cette
disposition là alors bien sûr ça peut
faire peur bien sûr on comprend pourquoi
on préférerait à la rhétorique parce que
on arriverait en disant j'ai des
recettes de cuisine j'ai plus qu'à les
appliquer et hop ça va marcher mais
rassurez vous il ya des techniques et
ses techniques là bas vous permettent
d'être capable d'improviser être capable
de trouver le mot juste
alors en quelques mots je vous parlais
de ces techniques comme c'est des
techniques d'interprète
autrement dit on incarne sa pensée ce
sont des techniques qui sont liées au
corps qui partent du corps est bien
content vous disant ça j'en profite
aussi pour vous dire que en ce moment
même au 27 boulevard des italiens
stéphane andré qui est le fondateur de
l'école de l'art oratoire où je
travaille dispense une master class
c'est à dire un cours ouvert au public
on vient s'entraîner parce qu'il ya que
l'entraînement physique qui va faire que
vous allez trouver une aisance dans la
technique
alors en quoi consiste-t-elle cette
technique en quelques mots
d'abord c'est se relier à son auditoire
puisque l'enjeu c'est de trouver le
texte juste par rapport à cet auditoire
et bien encore faut-il que je prenne en
considération son existence et ça c'est
ce regard qui nous lie qui va faire que
vous allez à travers mon regard enfin
que je vais à travers mon regard
enregistrez votre existence
et chacun y reçoit sans signe par
seconde et vous envoyer à votre cerveau
en permanence sans jamais rompre le
regard un état de votre salle et votre
cerveau brunstein survie structure une
pensée qui pète pertinente pour votre
public par instinct de survie
et ouais pour essayer faut essayer faut
s'entraîner faut lâcher prise faut
oublier toutes les façons dont vous avez
pu parler d'un sujet et repartir à zéro
en rencontrant votre public
mais si vous êtes relier vous y arrivez
l'autre chose donc ça c'est une clé le
regard qui est fondamental tout part de
là l'autre chose c'est de pouvoir
s'engager physiquement et d'une certaine
façon c'est à dire je vous donnais ce
que l'on appelle la clé dans notre école
c'est la verticalité je développerai pas
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de choses à dire
retenez une chose de la verticalité
c'est que l'idée aussi la verticalité
c'est qu'elle nous permet de ressentir
c'est à dire qu'on ne bloque plus son
corps qu'on se met plus en apnée qu'on
autorise son corps à respirer et donc à
ressentir et en ce moment j'ai des
émotions en vous regardant et moi même
j'accède à une meilleure compréhension
de ce que je raconte
par le biais de l'émotion laurent
terzieff qui était un grand acteur est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup écrit sur le
théâtre et qui disait on accède à la
compréhension par l'émotion si en
ressentant ce qui se passe autour de
vous que vous êtes capable aussi
d'orienter votre pensée pour y répondre
au mieux les neurosciences ne disent pas
autre chose
si on ne sent pas on ne peut pas
répondre de la façon la plus pertinente
à son environnement
donc rené ça le corps entre autres pour
cette raison majeure qui être capable de
ressentir pour pouvoir produire quelque
chose de pertinent sur la base d'un
regard qui nous envoie en permanence la
réalité de ce que vous êtes et enfin
dernière clé la voix le vouloir vocal on
dit dans notre jargon à nous des cols de
l'art oratoire la voix pourquoi la voix
parce que quand on vous avez une voix
qui est bien placé quand on entend
toutes les harmoniques tous les toutes
les nuances de votre voix à ce moment là
les nuances de votre pensée circule
aussi c'est à dire que des informations
sans voix ça reste un texte plat un
texte qui ne change rien ça reste
justement purement informatif et l'ag
vous citez beckett qui dit quelque chose
que j'aime beaucoup
il dit lorsqu on se parle ce n'est pas
pour échanger des informations
ou peut être con mais pas à ce point là
et donc lorsqu'on se parle c'est pour
échanger la sensation de ce qu'on dit au
moment où on le dit et à travers votre
voix une voix qui est bien placé on
entend les émotions que vous même avez
lorsque vous parlez et cette émotion là
aussi touche le public et vous récupérez
cette façon-là public dont le public a
été touché par votre regard est donc là
on a un système
alors bien sûr ce système il travaille
le regard ça se travaille savoir
respirer savoir tenir une verticalité
vous verrez regarder et tenez vous
pouvez faire ça comme exercice
rien qu'avec ces trois clés regarder des
orateurs regarder des politiques et
demandez vous où est-ce qu'ils en sont
de leur regard est ce qu'ils regardent
en permanence leurs partenaires leurs
adversaires est ce qu'ils savent se
tenir et leur voix est-ce qu'elle
transmet une émotion essaie juste de
l'info technocratique qu'on fait passer
et qui remuent personnes
et qui ne fait rien avancer du coup
parce que ça crée aucun désir donc
entraîner vous venez nous voir à la
master class de stéphane c'est tous les
premiers jeudis du mois à l'entrée est
libre
aller plus loin sur ce chemin parce que
un corps qui étaient équilibrés un corps
avec des techniques et bien c'est votre
pensée incarné de façon juste qui
circulent dans le monde et plus on aura
des pensées claires et justes et
pertinentes par rapport à
l'environnement un plus riches sera la
circulation de la pensée dans le monde
donc ça vous appartient il n'y a plus
qu'à yapluka il ya plus qu'à essayer
voilà je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté
merci beaucoup